hey on today's show we are talking about
adult themes so watch out for the little
ears in the room
we talked to a dad whose 14 year old
daughter came home and announced she's
bisexual and he wants to know what to
say and do
next we talk to a woman whose 12 year
old son is addicted to pornography
addicted to horror movies and she wants
to know what to do
and we talked to an awesome mom who has
a sister-in-law who's a former addict
and wants to keep the kids stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john dolone show thank you for hanging
out with us i'm so glad that you're here
we got a lot going on today and i'm glad
that you are along for the ride
we're going to talk about relationships
mental health parenting all of it right
everything you can imagine we're going
to talk about today on the show um
give us a shout at 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com show fill out
the form it goes to kelly
and she makes the decisions as to
whether we all live
or die and speaking of kelly and
james here's what just happened just now
fresh off the presses
another deloney screw up
i left all my stuff in the other studio
i went
to grab it and evidently nope i might
even say evidently
evidently is what people say when they
are apologizing for something that they
don't think they should be apologizing
for it's like evidently i hurt your
feelings you're evident
i walked into a studio and i missed the
big
red neon light that says recording and i
just busted in the middle of someone
else's session and screwed up the whole
session
and in the engineering world that's the
gravest sin
unplugging is probably the number one
sin
the second sin is walking in so on
behalf of america
and the 17 listeners kelly
james i'm sorry proud of you for taking
ownership of that
not evidently i'm just sorry i hope that
you're kelly just looked at me like this
i don't really give a crap hurry up and
get to the calls i'm just stupid
apologies are dumb
she told me she had an ocular migraine
with my name on it
that means that your head hurts because
you're looking at my face
well i was saying i was having an
aneurysm and then we created the little
instead of my baloney has a first name
it's my my aneurysm has a first name
and we went to loney so well um
well i'm not sorry about that i'm sorry
about everything else but not that zack
i'm even sorry to you too fresh start
let's do it
fresh start put your bricks down delony
they're always making fun of me i got
loads of whatever all right so let's get
right to the phones let's go to john in
oklahoma city john what's up brother how
are we doing
uh we're doing all right thank you for
taking my call you bet man thanks for
calling how can i help
oh okay i have a 14 year old daughter
and
uh it's recently come to her mother's
and i attention
that she believes that she is a bisexual
okay
now um she is a
very easily influenced young girl and
has always had trouble making and
building relationships
her mother and i feel that she is being
influenced by a group of young people
she just wants to fit in with
okay um i'm trying uh and
my wife is trying to figure out how do
we discuss with her
about uh whether or not this is a real
thing where she's being
influenced um we're we're having
difficulty navigating this
and um and i would i would really
appreciate it if you wait in and help me
out
yeah you betcha so um first thing here
most importantly i want to
applaud you for having the courage to
make this call and
our churches aren't great places to ask
these questions anymore workplace isn't
great places to ask these questions
anymore
and so i have over the last five six
seven years i've just
dealt with parent after parent i've sat
with mom and after dad
after mom after dad just ringing their
hands saying how do we best love our kid
right and how do we we want our kids
lives to be great
and smooth and simple and
um gender and sexuality issues
um mental health challenges physical
health challenges what major they're
gonna have
how beautiful they are how beautiful
they're not anything you can imagine
a parent just wants their kids life to
be peaceful and smooth
and the hardest thing is when we realize
they're not right because they're kids
they're people right
so right i applaud you man i can hear it
in your voice
um that this is weighing on you so i
want to i want to step back
way back and i want to speak to you and
i'm going to speak to the greater
audience here too and then we can drill
down to your answers very specifically
okay
so first and most important and i never
want you to lose this because
this she she comes home as a 14 year old
and declares
i'm bi right this is going to be one of
the
many many declarations she makes over
the course of her lifetime right
yes uh it was something that she
actually was withholding from us because
she didn't know how
we we would react and we just kind of
happened to find out
okay uh so we sat down and talked with
her about this
um but i don't believe we handled it
very well had the conversation going
on how did it go um well my uh
my wife and i love her to death uh but
she
said you know this isn't how you're
raised these aren't the values that we
believe in
and um i ended up taking her out to
dinner
and her and i just sat and talked and i
told her i said look if
this is the way that you are then that's
okay because i love you
but i do want you to understand you know
that
if you're being influenced by other
people
that if you make declarations like this
these things kind of stick with you for
a very long time if not lifelong because
sometimes people
uh bring these things up as a way to
mock and ridicule and
kind of laugh and
so my wife is not handling it near as
well as i am
i'm trying just to let her know that and
understand that i love her
and i love her deeply and that's never
going to change no matter what
but i would rather her get firmer values
and
figure out where they're coming from and
not allowing other people to influence
her
and and um and and
trying to mold herself into what other
people
want right um because then that's
conditional love and i want her to
understand that that's not the kind of
love you're trying to chase after
and i'm just having a hard time
explaining this or
because let's face it i'm dead and i'm
not sure that she's really listening
so here's here's what i want to tell you
um
she's not going to listen to you she's
going to experience you
and the fact that you picked her up from
that from
your wife's um comments and took her to
dinner
took her and changed the environment
took her to a safe space looked her in
the eye and said
above all else and below all else and to
the east and west of all else
i love you and that's gonna
be something that will reverberate in
her heart and mind for the rest of her
life
as will when she had the courage to come
and declare
anything right and it's this is a third
rail issue for some folks and so
we focus on what the declaration was
but the fact that she declared a thing
that she had been un
like worried to declare and she was
initially met with
how dare you right that confirmed in her
i was right to hyatt
i was right to squash who i am i was
right to
and not even who i am i was right to
squash who i think i am at 14
right and so what you did was
um noble and remarkable and hope every
dead in the united states follows that
same trajectory
that when their kid comes home and gives
them any sort of declaration that's
different from the picture that we have
in our minds for our kids and i don't
care who you are
you've got an imaginary picture for your
kid right
no matter what how different that looks
like
you said hey i love you to the moon and
back first
and good for you all right so let's i'm
gonna back way up here and just use this
as an opportunity to have a broader
conversation and then we'll drill in
okay
um it sounds like you know this but i
just want to say it out loud
our sons and daughters are not issues
for us to solve
she's your daughter right and our kids
are not
soccer stars they're not future teachers
or engineers or high school dropouts
they're our daughters right they're not
anxiety disorders or a spark
plug or a wall flower or a high school
dropout or any other label we can put on
them
they're our daughters right and
very similar to spouses often uh parents
we respond to any sort of
threat to our status quo right any sort
of thing that makes us uncomfortable
with what
advice and we have been told over and
over
that we all need to have the same
answers all the right words all the
right directions and our goal is to make
sure kids have all the right information
knowledge coaching advice right
and we've also come to believe that our
kids are reflections of our successes
or our failures they complete us and
that their failures are permanent their
feelings are permanent their responses
dreams high school grades first second
third majors in college
all this is forever and if anything gets
off the rails they are failed
they are broken and all is lost right
and so now
you and me are the same we spend so much
of our energy and time and worry paving
the way so our kids can have these easy
transitions
easy times and smooth paths to paths to
wherever it is they're going
and the heart behind that is good man
but the the
result is not so i'm going to give you
an example okay
um this happened to somebody that i care
about
um and it's not my wife okay
so this person said daddy um i want to
be a teacher
like as a child let's say 12 year old 13
year old that i'm gonna be a teacher
and the dad's response was that job
doesn't make any money
you are so smart why in the world would
you waste your
brainpower on being a teacher you should
be a doctor a surgeon or a lawyer right
don't don't waste it being a teacher and
what the daughter heard
was not the factual like that's actually
correct you make more money
being a doctor that's true
but what that little girl heard was your
feelings are wrong
you're dumb my feelings about you are
right in fact
you can't be trusted and you will always
need to bounce your feelings and dreams
off me
and that spirit and fire and wind that
swirl and burn inside of you
are not to be listened to or trusted you
call me and when i'm out of the picture
you call somebody else right and this is
how
kids learn to disassociate from their
bodies how they learn not to trust
themselves
and how they learn how to need other
people to give them self-worth which is
the exact thing you're worried about
right
it's how they learn how to look for
value in other people
and insight about themselves and other
people because clearly
they can't do it on their own right and
so
what if my daughter said
hey dad i want to be a teacher and my
first thought was
oh my gosh i know what teachers make
you're going to starve
but instead i said tell me about that
tell me about being a teacher
what does your teachers give to you that
you would love to give to other people
right if you're ever interested i would
love to
give you some money and you can get some
ice cream with mr aaron or miss tally
and go learn about being what what
really being a teacher is all about
right
and so now you're teaching your daughter
how to listen and hear and feel her
feelings and how to demand
evidence from her feelings right how to
paint a picture of her feelings and see
them and know them
how to learn to trust herself how to
learn to believe in herself
and you dad mom become a trusted
confidant you become a trusted person a
safe person
and there's going to be times this is
the example that i love that
mcconaughey gave me was man your job as
a parent is to let them climb trees
even when you know they're gonna fall
off the bottom couple of limbs your job
is to make sure they don't get on that
one limb that
ain't no coming back right and so there
is these moments and you got to climb up
and do that so take me back to this
moment you guys discover it
you guys what does that mean did you she
posted somewhere did a friend's mom call
you how did you guys find out
she um receives rides to school from
the lady who lives next door and um
this was something that my daughter had
shared with her um apparently because
she was scared to share it with us
and um and you're right by the reaction
that she uh
she received by her parents uh her
intuition was right
yeah yeah um so
we uh i'm sorry i'm a little bit nervous
no man you're good you're you're brave
and you're good i appreciate you
yeah we we began to to talk with her
and um i think it was just my wife just
kind of launched in
and um was just telling her you know
this is
this is not how you are and i think a
lot of it has to do with
how i i believe um
other people are viewing um my wife and
i
as if we're failures as far as parents
and when i say other people i'm
talking generally about family members
um
how how uh how family members sometimes
just judgmental
and um and and i think some of this is
actually that we're worried that we're
gonna receive
shame by who she is and um
the longer that i think about it the
more that i believe that i
i think i'm just going to have to be
okay with that kind of a shame because i
love my daughter too much
oh man that's so good
that to me is what
protecting your kid looks like not
taking your kid and beating them head
over stick because a 14 year old made a
declaration
dude as a society we have decided 14
year olds can't drive
they can't um buy beer
they can't buy a lottery ticket we have
put so much
pressure right on these kids
and it and you know this um as the
parent but for those who don't
there this is new this is an emergent
cultural
issue that's emerged in middle schools
especially in high schools
is this um declaration generation like
you have to walk around and say this
is this is who i am forever no
14 year old is who they are forever
that's not a real thing
right so whenever whenever a parent
i get that i have a picture for you and
suddenly
it looks different and again it's going
to be of course across a number of
different things
that initial conversation everything
floods your brain right religion
politics desire to keep your
daughter from ridicule pain any sort of
hurt and like you just said
boldly man like i don't want to face the
music on this deal
or we've got family members who are
going to challenge us or
our local community church or fill in
the blank and you want to shut it down
give her advice give her religious
perspectives
and the rules of life and here's what
she's feeling from you
your feelings and thoughts are wrong
you cannot be trusted and even bigger
there is a line to where me as mom won't
love you anymore
there is a line to where the god of the
universe cuts you off
right and so instead of launching into
a response to a kid who
followed her gut and shouldn't have told
you right and i'm telling you what she
did i'm glad she did tell you
um when she says i think i'm bi
what if their response was hey tell me
about that where's that coming from
um where these thoughts coming from it's
it's super normal to think so and so and
so and so is
pretty and attractive and to want to
emulate and want to be like to want to
experience things to want to be desired
which is when the core
human feelings that we all desire tell
me about that
right and now what you're teaching a kid
is
um hey this is a safe place
that i can go to for the rest of my life
with should i
marry so and so should i buy this house
should i move into this place
hey we're having twins like that's a
safe place to
i can go back to and back to him back to
and more importantly
you're teaching your daughter how to
speak out loud how to have these
feelings and emotions and thoughts
and then how to lay them out and demand
evidence from them right
is this real or am i getting this from
somebody else do i just want to be
accepted with this group of people
i went through phases where i was a one
a poser skater i was a poser metal kid i
was a poser
jesus freak kid i was all kind of poser
kids because man i was just trying to
find out who i was
i was trying to find out my identity
right and so
when a kid gathers up the courage and
strength and bravery and says something
like this
it's both awkward and deeply true and
deeply she's 14
right and so the issue here for me
is not nearly as important as what you
did man
john and i got to just commend you on it
it's not nearly as big as
i love you and you're my daughter and
i'm a safe person you can always trust
you can always bounce things off you
and i'm going to hear you i'm going to
listen i'm going to love that doesn't
mean
you have to agree with everything that
doesn't mean you've got to just
hoot and holler and run down the street
and um
you know throw confetti it doesn't mean
those things it means that your daughter
knows i'm loved i'm tethered in here
then that when you're tethered in then
you can have those conversations about
hey tell me where the stuff tell me tell
me what you're thinking tell me where
your heart is on these things
i do think this i do think there is a
an immense um it's insanity
the pressure that these young people are
under to quote unquote declare
and i think it's mostly social and i
think it's mostly social media
and um if i'm in your situation my
i mean this is me judging another dad so
take this for what you will
but my 14 year old is not going to have
a lot of places to make any declarations
does that make sense right um she's not
gonna have social media as a 14 year old
girl no chance no way know how
um the research is too clear on that
stuff she's not going to have these
platforms by which she can quote unquote
say something she can never get back
and for whatever it's worth her
classmates aren't going to hold stuff
over her
they don't care anymore right or a
number of them don't care anymore
um even at the multiple christian
colleges i've worked at people want to
get on with their day
it's those of us who are parents those
of us who have understood life in
different ways that are really
struggling with some of these broader
conversations
what about you and your wife's
relationship here i don't think that
this has
uh affected our relationship um
i i think a lot of it is is that i'm
trying to
to get her to
i i guess the the bigger thing is is
that we can't make her do
anything or make her not do anything
we can impose consequences um for for
certain things but we can't
make make her do or not do anything
and in getting my wife to understand
that we can't change her behavior
she's going to do what she's going to do
she's going to weigh the
the consequence but she's still going to
do what she's going to do
even when we're not around um trying to
get my wife to understand that it's just
difficult yeah i know that's hard and
i'll i'll even challenge you a little
bit you could you could lock her down
man
you could and i've seen it happen and
i'll tell every parent listening to this
i've had that kid multiple times over at
my college
in my office looking for some place to
anchor into because they know for sure
mom and dad aren't safe
now that doesn't mean you don't hold
kids accountable that doesn't mean you
don't
inject wisdom into their life that
doesn't mean you let them run wild
right that's not we're talking about
here what we're talking about at the end
of the day is
a 14 year old
sat down and said hey i'm having these
kind of feelings and the
in the instant response was damn those
feelings
right get those out of here and so
what i would what i would challenge your
wife on is this
and of course in a respectful kind
loving way um all right let me just i'll
just be honest with you
parents who totally totally disagree
um fundamentally from a faith
perspective even from a science
perspective whatever
i can't tell you the number of parents
who have called me and said i wish i
could have that first conversation back
when it comes to my kids saying hey i
think i am gay i think i am bi i think i
am filling the blank
how they most wish they could have that
first conversation back
and so if if i'm your wife and my
daughter came and
again put anything on the table for me
whether it's this particular thing that
happens to be a third rail right now
if she put down hey i am dating a 17 and
a half year old boy and there's nothing
you can do about it
i love him and i'm going to be sexually
active and fill in the blank
and or i am going to such and such
concert and there's nothing y'all can do
you can lock me in my room i'm gonna
find a way out whatever the thing is
right if you first initially meet that
with hey thanks for telling me
we love you and don't say i love you no
matter what just say i love you
i love you thank you for sharing that
with us now let's talk about that
right man you are setting up a situation
that defuses that initially and you're
setting up a
long-term relationship with your kid
that if you ever do want to
influence belief and influence value and
influence
um religious viewpoints and scientific
viewpoint
it all comes back to that anchored
relationship that's why
kids are leaving churches in droves
that's why kids are
cutting their parents out in droves
because they're going to places where
kids will just
listen to them right well they just feel
safe right
kids will take accountability they'll
take hard conversations if they trust
where it's coming from
here's my guess john my guess is this
isn't the first time your daughter's put
something out there that your mom that
your wife has
pushed back really hard on her is that
fair
yeah maybe she wanted to play soccer and
she says no in this house we do this or
like give me an example of something
um
my daughter has been into a great number
of things
and finally we just got to the point
where we said okay if you're going to
commit to something you're going to
commit we're not going to
let you back off anymore so right now
it's guitar
she she decided she wanted to be into it
so now we're
we're pushing really hard hey we're
going to follow through with this and
um does that create some tension in the
home
oh yeah yeah it creates a great deal of
tension i
i work an awful lot and uh so i
i guess what a lot of this is is that my
wife has to deal with so much because i
i'm just
not there for the initial moments of
these things um
so and i feel i feel a great deal of
guilt about that but i got that
yeah yeah i got that man i can hear it
on you man
um so for whatever it's worth in this
particular situation
you pulled your daughter out of a hard
response and you took her out
and you changed locations and you look
tonight said i love you and i want to
commend you for that
okay i want to commend you for that um
there's a difference between
what you think about what she said and
what that ramifica all that will come
in due time but the right thing in that
right moment is to hug your kid and say
thank you for trusting me i love you
right i want every single solitary
parent to hear me say this
your kids are not issues they are not
their achievements they're not their
accomplishments they're not their
screw-ups
they're your son they're your daughter
in all of these conversations all of the
lgbt stuff
all of the what am i going to be when i
grow all of that is rooted out of
you are welcome and safe to come sit
down and talk to me
and you want him to come back again and
again and again
and again and it starts with those
initial responses there
and so if i could tell your wife
anything it would be stop trying to win
interactions you can crush a child
that's simple
right parents can do that i lock you up
you're grounded till you graduate
i spent several of my summers growing up
as a child grounded for the whole summer
the whole summer man like and i deserved
it too by the way
um you can crush a kid that's simple
can you anchor one in so that they can
truly hear you truly feel safe truly
feel loved
and then you can have these deep broader
conversations and just like you said
john
at some point you got to get to a place
where i can't
i cannot decide who my kid's going to be
attracted to i can't
i can decide whether i love him or not i
cannot decide
when my kid's 18 and leaves a house i
can decide not to fund their college i
can decide not to pay the rent all that
yes
but they're going to be they're going to
be are they going to be my son and my
daughter are they going to go
right so thank you so much for your
heart there john i appreciate that call
so much
um again reach out at johndaloni or
um shoot us an email at johndaloni.com
if you got more questions there
appreciate your heart man all right
let's go to ashley in shreveport
louisiana ashley what's going
on how can i help hi dr john
how are you i'm doing good how are you
good good good so what's up
uh well basically um i have a 12 year
old son that has
adhd and asperger's syndrome
and he's right now he has a fixation
on horror videos subjects
and pornography and his
counselor that we've been seeing for
we've
for a couple of months he doesn't seem
to
feel like it's a big deal but we really
do
he's 12. he's he's 12.
oh my gosh well stop seeing that
counselor
today geez louise what a [ __ ]
why would he say that's not a big deal
i i don't know he's he's addressed it
with them but he
always just kind of well you know i
think you're
you know you're above that you you know
that shouldn't be something you
you know you would be interested in but
he's 12.
every 12 year old on the planet is
interested in naked people
that's why they have got parents that
get between them and viewing naked
people why because they're
children god almighty any counselor that
says uh it's
i mean they shouldn't but it's cool dude
should not be a therapist
especially a child therapist
unbelievable man
just this just the scientific research
about how these poor kids are blowing
the herdonic sensors out of their back
of their heads
with i'm getting fired up and this is
not at you ashley you are beautiful and
lovely and wonderful and i'm glad that
you called
i am just can't believe my own ears that
therapist would do this
if a 12 year old is coming to see me
this is a red alert moment
because the research on these kids who
start looking at pornography at young
ages
are unable to have erections at 23
24 they are unable to hold relationships
they are
melting their sexual partners because of
their
uh misguided understanding of what sex
is they're getting sex education from
pornography
and this is a stop the presses moment
for me
this is pull all the internet on my
house if i have to turn every screen off
in my house if i have to
i'm not going to put that garbage in my
kids head i'm not going to let them have
access to it in any way shape form or
fashion
ever i don't care if they have
asperger's or add or anything like that
right
and the same's gonna go with um horror
movies quite frankly when it comes to
what kind of horror are you talking
about
um i mean it's anywhere from
like friday to 13th all the way through
he's got fixations on serial killers and
actually actually where is he getting
this stuff
he's he's hearing about it he hears
about it from his friends
and the worst part is now that
he's back in school they all have
chromebooks
and he gets on and we'll look at his
history and
he'll do maybe five or ten minutes of
class work and then he's on youtube and
he's just
searching and just no listen
you are all in the school um
principal's office tomorrow at 8am you
take the day off of work if you got to
because those are supposed to have
filters on them
he's a child they're supposed to have
filters on them they're supposed to not
be able to just surf the web they're
supposed to
have a lot of breaks in those
chromebooks right and i was intentional
about asking those questions with my kit
you get in there that morning and enough
12 year olds should be watching radar
movies
in school they shouldn't be watching
them at all for god's sakes man
yeah and again this is has nothing to do
with diagnostics
kids are into things that get their
heart rate racing
right that's their kids and this is not
about his diagnostics this is about the
fact that he's 12
right 12 year-old boy wants to check out
naked people he's 12 year old boy that
wants to check out
cool exciting ooh and ah violent crazy
things
right and that's a parent's job that's a
school's job that's a counselor job it's
a teacher's job to protect these kids
actually so i would be all up in there
and if not i'm gonna throw that computer
in there and then we're going to do this
thing the old school way because i'm not
going to have my kid
in that poison and that trash no chance
no way no how
we can't help the conversations that our
kids are having
with their classmates i actually don't
those don't bother me they give me a
great
avenue into my son's heart and my
daughter's heart and so i like hearing
about words that they've learned and
conversations and
some of them are hard and uncomfortable
but that gives me a great avenue to have
conversations with my kid right so and
they're going to have that
for the rest of their life they're going
to hear stuff at college they're going
to hear stuff at the workplace they're
going to hear stuff at some local
bar having a beer with their buddies
they're going to hear those things so
that doesn't bother me
because those are other 12 year olds
what bothers me is
there's no adult stepping up in this
kid's life man that are saying
not on my watch you know what i mean
yeah yeah i do you're you're at a burn
the ships moment ashley
for the heart and mind of your son okay
okay
right and i i hate i just wanted i want
to make sure it wasn't just
us i didn't feel like we were
overreacting but
when we when the you know the
professional tells us that
we are nonsense you tell that [ __ ] to
call me
on my own show i'd love to talk to him
i would love to right or take this
youtube clip and uh whenever it comes
out
and then email it to him and say we want
i want to discuss this at the next
session
except hopefully by the time this comes
out you're not having any more sessions
jesus louise
um and by the way is this the same guy
that diagnosed your
child as add slash asperger's
no that was that was a psychiatrist
several years ago okay we we switched to
this guy because because we kept having
that reoccurring problem with him
searching for things and and they
and the group suggested that we meet
with him because he may be
more open to talking to someone to
talking to a male instead of a female
sure counselor that's and that's fair
kids kids
will talk to different people with
different levels of comfort that's
awesome
but when you're working with a child you
have to remember that when
your kid is seeing a child counselor
psychologist
what you the parent are the actual
client there
you get to talk through what the
treatment is going to look like
not that you get to decide what the
outcome is going to be but you get to
come into those and say my kid
is already developing a pathology an
addiction towards
pornography we've got to stop this and i
need some help
and if a therapist is going to say well
i don't really do that i do guided
directive therapy with 12 year olds and
say
you're an idiot and then go find
somebody else that's going to help you
solve this
immediate crisis of a problem with your
12 year old
okay now here's the other thing if your
child truly is on the
um autism spectrum right
and again i want you to go have somebody
else check this
anytime somebody just throws asperger's
in add that's actually the language
isn't even what they use anymore
they've got different language for that
diagnostic and so i'd recommend getting
that tested
and see but man if you start developing
some of these long-term patterns from
these long-term
loops with somebody on the autism
spectrum disorder
it is unfathomable how hard it will be
to unwind some of that
a kid with adhd tendencies who's coming
from a chaotic
situation who maybe doesn't fit in a
traditional classroom and so we're just
going to label him
that's a whole other conversation but
that kid is going to suffer from this
addictive this looping this routine
driven this chaos pushing
man he's going to be searching search
and searching so we've got to get extra
intentional
now about having alternative behaviors
alternative things
and for a 12 year old that means
complete restriction
not learning to live with not hey listen
ashley your mom gut was right
your mom heart was right
okay okay listen yeah follow your gut
follow your heart you know that boy
better than anybody okay
all right uh thank you all right so
listen
you didn't screw anything up you
listened to the professionals you did
what they told you to
and i'm super glad that you called um
it's time to get
in it's time to it's time to turn into
advocate mama
it's time to go be war mama now and
again you're in that school office 8
o'clock tomorrow morning show the
history
and say this is not going to happen and
it's not up to the 12 year old to not go
to these sites because they're 12.
right good grief and drive me crazy all
right let's take one more call from
renee
in toledo ohio and then um
i'm just going to go lay out in the
woods or something all right let's go
what's up renee how are we doing
how are you doctor john how are you
doing i'm doing good how are you
doing good thanks all right so what's up
i'm so glad they get to talk to you
i'm glad that you called it's awesome
what's up so my husband and i have had a
dilemma
his sister has had a
on and off again drug addiction for
about 20 years now
about two years ago she started cleaning
herself up and now she has her kids back
and she's living on her own and she
wants
now for my kids to come over and spend
the night
yes and we're having a hard time
trusting
what goes on there okay if i have to
have a hard
conversation with her i don't want it to
deter her from how you know from
any progress that she's made right i
don't want to be judgey or anything like
that okay
so there's a difference between being
judgey and keeping your kids safe
okay so take the judgy part off and then
also take this off
of your heart and mind and soul you are
not responsible for the outcome of
somebody else's response to your
boundaries
that's their choice okay
here's my recommendation i push back
against the idea of sleepovers in
general
i'm not a huge fan of them if we do have
them they happen at my house
and that's that's more of a blanket
conversation
that i have not only with you know
particular family members that's just
who i tell everybody
right my friends if you want to do a
sleepover if my son
daughter wants to sleep over it's going
to be over at my house because i know
what goes on in my house
and mine's a lot more related to
internet stuff than it is
to um and running the streets man we
just snuck out i spent half my life
spinning on other people's houses and
we're just out running this roaming the
streets
um just because we'd walk out the front
door at somebody else's house and
i the world's different now and it was
stupid then
it's dangerous now right and so i
that's all before we even get to do i
really trust my sister-in-law
you know what i mean and so i that's
where i draw those lines
it's just looping back with my kids and
saying hey we're just we're gonna do
sleepovers we're doing we're gonna do
them here
um when it comes to actually having
boundaries with your sister-in-law
um if you don't feel safe you don't feel
safe you don't need to apologize to
anybody for that
on the other hand i know some folks who
have been in recovery who are
incredible people and they've got a past
that
that man makes my toenails curl
and i've seen a lot of wild stuff
and now they are incredible people right
and i wouldn't mind my son
i know that my senator would be safe
there it's my baggage at this point
right
and so you just guys just have to decide
if you all don't think she's there yet
she's not there yet and don't lose any
sleep over that
if you do think she's there and y'all
are just struggling then um that's up to
you guys
right but it's at the end of the day all
this is about not
people's feelings not people's is it
gonna hurt this is gonna make them set
it is about keeping my kids safe first
and foremost
okay and i know that's a lot easier said
than looking
a sister-in-law that's what i was
thinking easier said than done right
real cool idiot now i gotta sit down and
have this conversation i know it's gonna
be hard there's no question
um an easy way out of that conversation
is a simple we don't do sleepovers
i know your family we just don't do
sleepovers um that's a simple
conversation there
if you you guys love sleepovers you'll
have a group of friends and family that
you do this all the time with and
right you know your kids are going to
europe then it's a harder conversation
and it may be that instead of coming at
her with a
um we don't trust you
it would be a sit down conversation
about we are
bananas about screen time we're bananas
about people going to bed
we are bananas about language that's
used in the home
and i've had these conversations with
people i love dearly
right my parents are all about tech
and we send the kids over we tell them
remember
they're gonna my kids know oh worried go
for it
grandma and grump's house now dude we're
gonna be all we're gonna get ipads right
and we remind them hey we're those
lunatic
screen time parents and my parents are
like i know we know
and then they go to the zoo and they go
play right so but i put my boundaries up
there so it's less about i don't trust
you and more about hey these are my
expectations for every person on earth
can you meet those right and then you
are the one owning the boundary you're
not just
lobbing grenades at somebody does that
make sense
yeah absolutely and that can be a much
safer way to enter that conversation
than one that doesn't wreck people's
hearts and minds and again it's not
yours to own that but i also understand
you're
you're a good person and you don't just
want to melt somebody down for things
they did in the past
that's a great question i appreciate
your heart and i know that that's that's
a challenging place to be
all right so as we wrap up today's show
i'm going to make an admission here that
i haven't admitted before
and i don't want to say that i've lied
on the ask me any things i haven't
but i've just omitted i
occasionally really really really love
country music
especially old country music like um you
know cash and the murals of
and of the worlds i love them but i got
a buddy that i knew back in college
um who's just turned into a sensation
man he's incredible
and he had a new record out a few i
guess a year ago now
and dude it's so good man and i don't
want to be that guy being like you
should listen to my
but man he's super good he's a texas
country artist named erin watson and i
was looking through
some of my favorite aaron watson songs
and man
this song office 2014 album underdog
record
it's called that look and it goes like
this
she keeps it all together and i always
come unwound she's cool calm and
collected and i want to paint the town
and she's like a sunday morning and i'm
a dance hall saturday night she's like a
stained glass window i'm a lone star
neon light
she has another side that no one sees
but me she's the only one that brings me
to my knees
there's something about sinatra and a
bottle of chardonnay without a single
word
she takes my breath away and when she
gets that look in her eyes
when she gets that want you need to love
you
right now that kind of look in her eyes
she's always looking so fine that i
can't believe she's mine
and when those stars align in moonlight
and that girl's off the hook when she's
good she's good but even better when she
gets that
look if that's not a texas country song
just when she gets that look i love it
erin watson
my man this is the dr john dolone's show
[Music]
you